begin this morning with a federal
magistrate's decision to unseal the
search warrant used at former president
trump's florida home the release comes
four days after the fbi's search and
after attorney general merrick garland
took the rare step to request that the
details of that warrant be made public
trump and his legal team have fiercely
criticized the justice department but
ultimately raised no legal objection the
warrant shows that the fbi agents were
told to look for signs that official
records had been altered destroyed or
concealed its timing suggests
prosecutors believe they had probable
cause that a possible crime was being
committed deborah elfrong is in our
washington bureau with the latest
deborah good morning
good morning jeff this is unprecedented
not only does the warrant seek documents
related to the national defense but it
also suggests that the fbi is
investigating the former president for a
violation of the presidential records
act and obstruction of justice 2.
the newly unsealed warrant authorizing
the search of former president trump's
florida home reveals fbi agents removed
11 sets of highly classified documents
including some marked top secret and
some only meant to be viewed in secure
government areas
also removed 20 plus boxes of items
binders of photos the executive grant of
clemency for trump ally roger stone and
info about the president of france john
bolton served as trump's national
security advisor he's now a critic of
trump well i thought he handled them
carelessly i don't think he fully
appreciated the significance of the
classification procedures far more
telling them what was seized says
attorney jessica levinson is what the
warrant suggests what they need is
probable cause that there was a federal
crime that was committed and probable
cause that the evidence of that crime
is where they say it was in this case at
mar-a-lago agents executed the warrant
at mar-a-lago monday after a back and
forth between the fbi and trump over
documents starting in the spring
they were seen carrying several boxes
from the estate the search has sparked a
wave of violent threats against the
justice department and the fbi as well
as a political backlash from republicans
a spokesman for trump described the
search as quote a botched raid the
former president's attorney say that
trump declassified those seized
documents now the affidavit that led to
this warrant will no doubt reveal more
it's the foundation that led to this
warrant michelle the question is whether
or not the former president had the
right to declassify those documents
deborah afron thank you